foreign
Jeremy is in Martinsburg West Virginia
hi Jeremy how are you good afternoon
good afternoon thank you so much for
having me on sure how can I help uh so
my question regarding some Financial
anxiety that I'm going through
um I married my amazing wife in 2020 and
we've been on fire we paid off ninety
thousand dollars in debt and last summer
we just paid off our house
and you're probably thinking where's the
anxiety coming from and I guess I was
expecting like an office space moment
where I got Financial Freedom and no
care even though worries and what I'm
finding out is when I paid off the house
I went the bank account went from 230
000 down to 50 000 and it just had me
kind of shook I'm not sure
what steps I should be doing and I'm
afraid to even move at this point
so your anxiety is because you have less
money in your account
correct I'm afraid to be I'm afraid to
be wrong like I know where we came from
with the 90 000 in debt and I'm afraid I
don't know what to do with it like where
to move I know maybe 97 000 included
paying off your mortgage or that on top
your mortgage on top of that
a little on top of that 90 000 was uh
just regular debt how much was the
mortgage how much the mortgage of 185
000. okay so 275 000 has been paid off
since the covid quarantine Andrew got
married
correct and you didn't die
correct
a lot of stress
what do you do for a living
I'm a federal contractor God Almighty
kind of feels like you've been running
with your hair on fire for three years
and you finally just don't have anything
to be on fire about and it scared you
correct yes so here's a weird thing I
wish it wasn't the case man but here's
our bodies solve for the nerd word is
homeostasis it likes the way things have
always been
and that's why when somebody knocks off
50 or 60 or 70 pounds
if they haven't made an entire
environment change change their life
change their identity I am now somebody
who does X Y or Z their body will
scratch and Claw that 50 60 70 pounds
back on because that's what it knows
and your body knows fight or flight run
War it's all coming down
it has never practiced peace peace and
so dude you're not crazy you're not nuts
your anxiety alarms are ringing off the
hook as they should be because you are
in Uncharted water you just don't know
what to do when when you're not when the
water's not dumping over the side of the
boat when it's just calm and chill
and it's just it's gonna be a season
you're gonna have to practice and you
have to learn how to be still not create
chaos because there's none being created
for you right
right and it sounds like uh I know what
I'm talking about because this is the
pot talking to the kettle it's good to
meet you man
yeah I mean
you do think about I wasn't kidding
around what all you did
in the beginning of a pandemic and out
the back end of a quarantine and a
pandemic when when we were all an
unprecedented oh God I hate that word
um now uh uh stress levels
and in the middle of that you went ahead
and got married
so let's add some stress in the middle
of that you went ahead and paid off 275
000 and completely revolutionized your
life which means you turned up the
burners to the highest possible Heat
um while you were in all of these other
burners and the water was already
boiling and all of a sudden it all just
went off and got quiet
that makes sense
yeah I think I'm just looking to find
out what I should be doing now I guess I
guess I know that investing but we both
have Roth IRA if she has attention so
I'm just I'm not sure what to do now I
don't know what to do just breathe chill
that's it you start investing and being
outrageously generous you're 100 debt
free
make snow angels in your front yard
what's your what's your household income
um 150 before tax with no payments
right take your shoes off and go walk
around the backyard that grass is yours
now all that crap you used to pay
payments on let's take those payments
and put them in Investments
fill up your 401k fill up your Roth
fill up your envelope that says random
acts of generosity
and catch the single mom
pumping gas with the kids with The
Frayed clothes and our tires are bald as
a baby's butt roll the car over to the
car
tire place next door and put four tires
on her car and fill it up and have the
oil changed and pay cash for it and
smile and walk away and she'll never
know who did it because you're God's
angel that day because you now have
money
how's that sound
sounds great here's a common thing that
happens is we think and and again like
getting out of debt is a is a core tenet
of not being anxious
but we often forget that wherever we end
up we go with us
and so
if you thought there was going to be
some magic wand that suddenly you were
going to like yourself or suddenly you
were gonna not have any more shame from
when you were a kid or suddenly your dad
was going to call you and tell you how
proud he was and that call ain't coming
being debt free will set you free from
anybody any external chains that got you
but it may be now you could do the work
that you need to do to heal right stuff
you've been crap you've been carrying
around for a long long time yeah that's
that's possible it gets really quiet
then the voices kick up exactly it's
it's like uh you've experienced this I
have and I've just met with countless
couples who's the last kid moves out and
that house gets quiet and now we got to
learn how to have a new kind of life
because it's different now
you know we plan so intentionally that
the party just began when they left
[Laughter]
somebody Daniels my mom carrying a disco
ball into the house is he really caught
oh hey but hey let's let's like just
full disclosure
you and I I've asked you off air
as my life has transitioned since I've
taken this job
like I I there's this there's a this
there's a discomfort with the newness of
not running for my life anymore and not
feeling like the whole world's coming
down and being able to love my wife and
not being panicked in the middle of the
night when she's asleep six o'clock go
home we don't work at seven yeah go home
here you know that's there there's it's
an intentional act but the thing is it's
just I said this other thing with Megan
Kelly I was on her podcast if you want
to turn it on guys she's got a great
podcast those are podcasters making a
slack if you're driving down the road at
100 miles an hour and then you slow down
to 55 it seems like you're crawling and
she goes not an experience I've ever had
Dave
you haven't either
yeah I never slowed down to 55. no she
saw but she never got up to 100.
she's a law-abiding citizen